halo the franchise best known for one
thing
blowing up aliens
[Music]
whether they're elder or parasites that
will consume all life in the galaxy with
their unending hunger or their funny
little awkward and sometimes suicidal
creatures that make birthday noises when
you shoot them in the head we just like
to murder aliens
[Music]
yay indeed it's one of the biggest
reasons that we love halo hell it's the
reason that i love halo and keep coming
back to it iteration
after iteration
after iteration
after iteration
after iteration after iteration
after iteration
after iteration no matter how much it
hurts me
halo 5 i will forgive you but i will not
forget
yet while halo is all about the
splosions and the murdering there is one
game that doesn't completely fit in one
game that's not like the others i'm
talking of course about halo 3 odst or
as i like to call it halo 3 oost that'll
play on your tongue a little bit oozed
that says the cheese balls you see halo
3 odst is the game that should not be
not only is odst a complete tonal shift
for the franchise focusing on a more
somber small stake story it was also
created out of the ashes of a completely
different halo project and was made in
basically a single year this game should
be a complete and utter mess and yet
it's absolutely beautiful in fact for my
money halo 3 odst is far and away the
best campaign in the entire halo series
oh yeah i said it better than halo 2
with its annoying cliffhanger or halo
reach with this pretentious nihilism or
halo 5 with its well
everything just
just everything that game was more
confused than my gender hydem seeks over
infinity this game is mwah
i love you oozed never change so before
all of us get wrapped up in that new car
smell of halo infinite i want to explain
why this red-headed stepchild of the
franchise whose other entries have sold
millions of copies and revolutionized
gaming is actually the halo that matters
most
[Music]
after the success of a little game
called halo 3 in 2007 developer bungie
was able to buy itself out from parent
company microsoft yet despite being
newly independent and bright-eyed like a
college student taking a gap year as
part of the deal microsoft would
continue to own the rights to halo and
bungie agreed to continue making
exclusive halo projects for the time
being one such project was halo
chronicles a game made alongside peter
jackson's much hyped halo movie with mr
lord of the rings himself overseeing
production but because we can't have
nice things halo chronicles which was
reported to be an episodic interactive
movie a la the later xbox exclusive
quantum break was eventually cancelled
along with the franchise's feature film
debut at the very least peter jackson
went on to make great works of cinema
right after that with the
hobbit
movies
huh but with the halo chronicles
development team now sitting around
twiddling their thumbs and work on the
forthcoming halo reach just beginning
bungie realized it had just enough time
to create what producer curtis kramer
described as a mini campaign but they
only had about one year to make it to
which the development team presumably
said
challenge accepted you know when you're
already wearing glasses putting on
sunglasses doesn't have that same amount
of dramatic effect does it anyways with
a blank check to do whatever they wanted
lead writer joseph staton and design
director paul barton jr decided to try
and do something new with the halo
franchise
[Music]
right when you start halo odst instead
of the series typical operatic opening
number the first thing you're greeted to
is a haunting whaling saxophone
signaling that this isn't your grand
daddy master chief's halo
[Music]
like the music halo odst wasn't going to
be your bombastic space opera but
instead took its cues from an entirely
different genre film noir a cinematic
style defined by its distinct visual
aesthetic darkened city street setting
and brooding tone yet like any good film
noir story odst needed a good mystery at
its heart odst starts you off as an
orbital drop shock trooper one of the
iconic human troopers that were first
introduced in halo 2. specifically you
play as the rookie a silent protagonist
who joins up with their new odst squad
sadly on the same day as the events of
halo 2 some troopers never get any luck
the rookie squad drops into the earth
city new mombasa to help fight back the
covenant invasion just as the jumping
covenant carrier destroys half the city
knocking the rookies pot off course and
separating them from their squad waking
up hours later in the abandoned
nighttime streets the rookie is tasked
with uncovering what happened to their
squad as they try to avoid the roving
covenant patrols and it's these eerie
streets where that noirish atmosphere is
most palpable with that haunting piano
and saxophone accompanying you through
the dark city no other halo game has had
this sense of character and personality
so baked into its very soul
[Music]
yeah what sells the subtle dread most is
the game's choice of the odst as the
player's avatar until now every halo
game had you play as the master chief a
scientifically modified super soldier
whose armor is literally named after a
norse god's weapon you felt invulnerable
because
you basically were you know how
expensive this gear is son
tell that to the covenant but this game
importantly tosses all that away alas
poor master chief i knew him well
cortana
odsts are just normal humans and sadly
normal humans can't take on an entire
covenant army by themselves forcing you
to quietly and stealthily stalk the
streets of new mambasa to represent this
the game brought back the health bar
forcing you to scavenge for health packs
dotted around the city a surprising move
considering that the original halo had
been the one to help popularize
regenerative health in the first place
okay bring us energy shields online
please
if the master chief is a power fantasy
with a one note personality that players
could imagine themselves into the
completely silent rookie conversely is a
blank slate with zero personality that
actually puts players into the game
making you feel even smaller amidst the
towering skyscrapers
for a franchise known for throwing you
into the fray with bombast the quiet
world of odst instantly subverts
expectations and highlights the
perspective even further numbassa
allowed bungie to experiment with
another game design choice that they
would later utilize in their future
games like destiny an open world while
it wasn't a completely open sandbox
progress through new mombasa was less
linear than prior games and most
first-person shooters of the era do you
blaze through a covenant patrol hide by
going through nearby buildings attempt
to circumvent them all together by
taking another route or like me do you
get lost and end up wandering in circles
for 20 minutes that's uh
that's not the game's fault i i do that
in real life too
yeah this type of middle ground approach
between linear and open gameplay i truly
love and i think it still feels fresh
today with companies like dishonored and
death loop creator arcane still
experimenting with this all roads lead
to rome type of level design the
multiple but limited amount of
approaches allows for a curated and
well-designed experience that still lets
the player have agency in how they
tackle a given situation yet despite all
these changes that i've already
mentioned and their short timetable in
making this game bungie still managed to
find even more ways to experiment with
odst adding weapons like the silenced
smg a satisfyingly stealth focused
cousin to the iconic battle rifle they
also added in the visor which
highlighted enemies in your hud for an
even further visual flair there is even
a new covenant enemy type the engineer
which floated around giving shields to
nearby covenant and whose existence was
integral to the game's story yet if
broody stealth exploration isn't your
style don't worry because odsd still
delivers that typical halo action
goodness don't know why i became william
shatner there for a second but there you
go regardless whenever the rookie finds
a clue to his missing team's whereabouts
the game flashes back putting you into
the role of one of your squad mates
earlier in the day and in contrast to
the rookie each of these characters is
filled with personality nathan philly
and as buck plays his typical yet
charming swashbuckling leader type
because the only thing i regret about
you and me
not knowing you were spooked when we
first met
i would have been a lot less charming
romeo played by adam baldwin plays the
gruff weapons tech and alan tudyk's
mickey was the irreverent engineer hurry
up
but if you wanna do this be my guest
but this ain't a job you wanna rush also
between the three of them you get a nice
little firefly reunion which you know is
very appreciated
uh i scratched your ipod
however this does mean that we now need
summer cloud genitorius and marina
background and halo so
get on that 343. we better get jewel
state and halo infinite or i riot
honestly we just need jewel state and
everything i i think we can all agree
the cast is also rounded out by the
always amazing nolan north as dutch
though i do need to go a little sejoa on
you for a second because it's worth
mentioning that between odst's release
and today there has been a larger
cultural conversation about white actors
voicing black characters and how this
can often sideline actors of color from
finding work and also can highlight
stereotypes within the characters
themselves and how they're represented
within the work and sadly for my money
nolan north as dutch has aged badly in
this respect and this isn't me trying to
say that this game is bad i'm making a
whole video about why i love this game
and it's also not me saying that nolan
north is bad or racist or offensive when
he did this but it's worth looking at
these issues in older games not to hate
on them but in order to create
conversations about how the industry has
and can continue to grow i'm not here to
dictate the morality of this casting but
i'm here to ask you to think about it
and its effects the point is to create
discussions not dead ends in
conversations and speaking of which we
also have battlestar galactica's
underappreciated tricia helfer as dare a
military intelligence officer with a
romantic history with buck and buck
call me captain
i'll pass on that dance
but you can show me where to sit
dare is dead set focused on her own
mission in new mambasa and at the start
of the game assumes command of the odst
squad but ultimately ends up going out
on her own once buck's squad gets
separated in the botched landing and
dare despite being named after a really
terrible middle school anti-drug program
is a cool character mostly on the back
of helfer's fantastic performance yet
she sadly doesn't break the mold of the
aloof emotionless women characters that
have littered halo from the very first
game say what you will about halo 4 and
5 they did at least give cortana and dr
halsey more character moments than all
the other women in this franchise
combined come on chief
take a girl for a ride and that is the
only good thing i will say about halo 5.
okay that one level where you ran down
the side of that robot was kind of a
little bit cool however on the whole in
their short time on screen the
characters in odst have more personality
than almost every character in all the
other halo games sans sergeant johnson
that man has more personality in his
pinky than i will ever have in my entire
lifetime
so smile
well we still got something to smile
about beyond the characters though the
flashback levels bring that classic
blockbuster feel of a typical halo game
yet instead of the repetitive shoot
enemies reload and repeat cycle bungie
took full advantage of the shorter game
to make each level feel different by
building them around a unique set piece
one level places you on the edge of a
towering skyscraper fighting off
banshees while another sees you tearing
up a zoo in a warthog like admittedly
we've all wanted to do while another
sees you barely holding off covenant
waves as you blow up a data center and
even another has you hijacking a
covenant carrier every single level in
this game has huge cinematic beats that
bring that sense of scale and awe to the
proceedings that one expects from a halo
game yet despite this though the story
still feels surprisingly and
refreshingly small the odsts aren't
saving the galaxy like master chief but
just trying to evacuate civilians
minimize damage and get back home from a
battle that's already been lost you even
see the horrors as the covenant glass
the city the same exact horrific fate we
would see befall the planet reach in the
next game and honestly i really love the
smaller scale today and even when odst
was released we constantly have games
and even movies focus on the end of the
world or the galaxy and honestly it gets
a bit tiring having varying levels of
stakes in games allows us to invest more
in the stories being told sure don't get
me wrong i like to save the galaxy every
now and then but if you're doing it like
every other tuesday well does it even
feel worthwhile
do we do we even need a galaxy why why
can't the galaxy just save itself for
once wasn't always good to be me
huh huh yet one of the coolest aspects
of the flashback levels is how they
overlap with the rookies journey having
you traverse the same locations in both
timelines not only do you see how much
the city has changed in just a few short
hours the bombastic flashbacks are
filled with explosions life and multiple
other marines making a return to the
rookies lonely and quiet nighttime
escapades even more isolating however
you're not completely alone adding to
the creepy factor you'll start to notice
messages and hints directed at you by
the city itself
caused by the city's superintendent and
ai even further if you begin to look
around you you'll find malfunctioning
registers spewing up money or
phones ringing wait they they still have
phone booths in the 26th century i guess
in the halo universe they found out that
smartphones are actually terrible for us
huh is it sad that i want to live in
this alien invasion filled future rather
than the smartphone algorithm led
dystopia that we have now
is that too real regardless though if
you interact with these ringing slices
of nostalgia you'll discover one of
odst's best additions sadie's story
sadie's story is a fully dramatized
audio log narrative that tells the story
of
well uh
sadie sadie is a young girl trying to
survive the covenant's invasion in a
story that reflects inferno the tale of
dante's journey into hell written by the
poet virgil that's so pretentious it'll
even make your high school english
teacher say
[Music]
each person sadie meets on her journey
represents another level of hell like
lust or greed as she's helped by the ai
created by her father virgil get it the
ai's name is virgil because virgil wrote
inferno
it's smart god damn sadie's journey also
mirrors the rookies own journey out of
their own inferno because as you make
your way through the city and start to
find more clues about your team members
you'll begin to notice that the sun is
starting to rise even the music starts
to evoke a more hopeful tone as the dawn
approaches as the piano and saxophone
slowly stop dominating the score
[Music]
eventually you as the rookie meets up
with dare who reveals that she's been
trying to find a rogue covenant engineer
who by the way is absolutely adorable i
mean look at this little pink and blue
blob i love them so much they're so
freaking cute turns out though that this
engineer has been controlling the
superintendent the whole time in order
to help you and wants to defect to the
human side because their whole species
has been enslaved so uh yeah that means
that any time you killed an engineer in
this game you were killing an innocent
life so
have that weighing on your soul you
haven't killed any of them have you
no well maybe one or two
nice work
hooray for casual war crimes
thankfully though you and this adorable
little thing who apparently is a big fan
of trucks yes he is yes he is
meet up with buck and the rest of your
crew for one final climactic battle
across the new mombasa highway as you're
rescued just as the city is destroyed
it's an epic conclusion that doesn't
undercut the horrors of the events in
new mombasa or the small stakes of the
game yet still feels grand and important
at the same time leaving odst to finish
off on a high note
what can i say
was a hell of a night
[Music]
so
odst for me is a powerful experience
it's one of those unique games where all
the elements interweave together
marrying gameplay with the intentions of
the story the best games shouldn't just
be cinematic experiences with gameplay
in between but actually use the gameplay
to make you feel what the game wants you
to come away with and i think odst does
this the vulnerability of your character
is mirrored by your health bar and
stealth gameplay the juxtaposition of
the bombastic flashbacks and the lonely
new mombasa streets highlight each
character's isolation odst makes you
feel both the horrors of the covenant as
you watch this beautiful city slowly
being emptied then destroyed while also
making you understand it intimately as
you comb over it over and over and over
again and it's for all these reasons
that it still stands out amongst a huge
franchise all these years later despite
some aged elements
even more so it's what makes it
surprisingly more resonant now than it
was when it was released
when i set out to write this video i
only wanted to pay homage to a game that
i really really loved and felt was often
overlooked for its bigger siblings
yet
replaying odst in late 2021
it made me feel something deeper and and
feel a deeper
resonance with the game
odst is the story of a lone protagonist
isolated desperately trying to reconnect
with those who
just moments before
were right by their side
it's a game where you wander a city that
only a short while ago was filled with
life
but is now haunted by tragedy
death and pain that left no one
untouched
and you can still see the scars of it
and still despite our best efforts will
never be the same again even if it is
saved
what scrap of it can be saved
these past two years have been
incredibly isolating if you're anything
like me during this pandemic that has
defined 2020 and 2021 you probably felt
like the rookie
a passive observer to horrors that you
can't control despite just all you're
trying to do is reconnect with those who
mean
so much to you
we may not be
battling aliens but
i'm sure you resonate with that fact of
not being sure if you'll reach that new
dawn at the end
wandering the darkness of a city
wandering the streets of new mambasa
felt personal in a way that never did
before when i first played this game
so for the game to slowly build off of
memories of connection eventually
building to a triumphant conclusion that
may be tempered with sadness trauma pain
but still having hope in the face of all
those desperate circumstances
to still emerge from the isolating
depths of that inferno that journey
through that inferno to still find hope
and still find those you care for
feels more resonant than it did in 2009
few games especially a game made in less
than a year end up being a true standout
in one of the world's biggest franchises
this game was a risk it was dangerous it
could have been a horrible misstep for
the series all of that was certainly
possible
yeah it's because
it's because of that risk that possible
danger the fact that it tried something
new
is why odsd suddenly feels more resonant
today even years after it's been mostly
forgotten
games like odst are exactly what this
industry needs more of even decades
later games that are willing to take
chances even
no especially within franchises that
grow
more stagnant with each installment more
ingrained in what they're supposed to be
it's games like odst that stand the test
of time because they say something
meaningful not just with big explosions
but in the quiet moments and say
something different that stands out from
the rest of the franchise
it's only then
that they might have a chance to
continue to be meaningful
years
after other games
have been forgotten
to time
[Music]
so
[Music]
you